good evening and welcome to Tucker
Carlson tonight there is nothing in the
world worse than finding out that your
deepest fears are Justified that's the
nightmare scenario learning there really
is a zombie in the closet
let's say you're a kid and you've
convinced yourself that your parents
don't really love you they claim they do
they say it all the time usually without
looking up from their iPhones but you
can tell they don't really mean it they
don't seem sincere
and then one Christmas morning
confirmation you discover they've
forgotten about you presence any
presence they were busy that just
slipped their mind and said they've
spent all their time and all their money
buying gifts for a kid down the street
so all the things that you asked for
they gave to another nine-year-old you
have never met
how'd that make you feel
well you'd be crushed but you would also
be Vindicated you would know for a dead
certain fact that your parents really
didn't love you they're not even very
interested in you
that's how a lot of Americans felt last
night watching the House of
Representatives have prove yet another
massive Aid package for Ukraine
nothing against Ukraine but we could
probably use that money here right about
now
after a hundred years of virtually
uninterrupted wealth generation the
American economy appears to be faltering
in ways that are scary to anyone who's
paying attention even people who aren't
paying attention can sense there's
something really wrong
lots of people are not working those who
are working are getting poor quickly
thanks to inflation all of a sudden
everything is wildly more expensive have
you noticed we literally have a shortage
of baby formula right now did you think
that would happen in America ever and
yet it is happening and so is the
deadliest drug epidemic in our history
about a hundred and seven thousand of
your fellow Americans most of them young
people who should have had long
productive lives are instead dead they
have died from drug od's over the past
year this is the saddest thing that has
happened in our country in a very long
time
and yet Congress which claims to run the
country can't be bothered even to
acknowledge it much less do anything
about it
instead your representatives in
Washington just voted to send yet
another 40 billion dollars to the
Ukrainian oligarchs who paid off the
president's son
that's what happened and it's just the
latest check that Congress has cut them
you can add it to the approximately 14
billion dollars they've already spent on
Ukraine that brings the total as of
tonight to more than 54 billion dollars
how much is that well for perspective it
is more than we spent per year on
average on the war in Afghanistan a war
that began with a direct attack on the
United States
54 billion that's about as much as
Russia the country spends on its entire
Armed Forces over the course of a full
year
it is a ludicrous amount
and yet Congress happily approved it in
fact they allocated seven billion
dollars more than Joe Biden asked for
that's how excited they were to do it
so where's this money going oh that's
the best part Congress has decided to
fix all of the pressing problems that
need to be fixed except fix them in
Ukraine not here
so the main course of all of this
funding from day one has been to secure
Ukraine's borders because you know you
can't have a country Without Borders
they have to be secure
Nancy Pelosi strongly believes that
about Ukraine and so do her friends on
the Republican side so Ukrainian border
security is the main goal then there's a
problem of quote food insecurity not
here in Ukraine food's getting expensive
in Ukraine so we're going to spend 760
million dollars to fix that just in this
check
and not just in Ukraine
Congress was feeling kind of sporty also
added 150 million dollars for something
called the global Agriculture and food
security program because while we're
feeding Ukraine why not feed the rest of
the world we've got more food than we
can use
and of course that will obviously
include baby formula too because kids in
other countries need to eat
then there's another huge chunk of cash
to quote combat human trafficking now
not combat human trafficking in Texas
whereas now ubiquitous thanks to the
open borders with Mexico but to combat
human trafficking in Ukraine because
it's sad what's happening there but not
here that's not sad we're ignoring it
there's still more money to make sure
ukrainians have emergency shelter
because apparently more than a million
Americans aren't homeless tonight
there's 900 million to make sure
ukrainians have access to quote
entitlement programs our entitlement
programs they'll need them when they
arrive here as many will in other words
you can't afford to fill your truck but
you now get to pay the living expenses
of anyone who shows up in your country
claiming to be from Ukraine and you will
and then because paying off your friends
is always the real point of these
exercises in Washington there are
billions more dollars for Lloyd Austin's
former Employers in the weapons business
that would include 72 million dollars
for something the bill describes as
quote research development test and
evaluation in Ukraine
hmm now don't say bio Labs because
that's not allowed but honestly this is
weird Ukraine is a war zone and
therefore probably not a great place for
scientific research right now but
whatever
we're funding some kind of science
experiments in Ukraine no more questions
from you and the bill goes on like this
and on and on
as Congressman Thomas Massey has pointed
out Congress has now spent more money on
Ukraine in six months than the U.S
government spent on all roads and all
bridges in the United States over all of
last year
the 40 billion dollars we're sending to
Ukraine so they can secure their borders
by the way is more than double more than
double what Joe Biden has asked to fund
Customs and Border Security in the
United States
one bill more than double what we're
spending this year on our borders
and then in the middle of this historic
drug emergency and it is the bill spends
more than 10 times the entire budget of
the DEA
more than 10 times just in case you're
wondering how your leaders feel about
you they're not fans at all and now we
know for sure
you should know that every single
Democrat in the House of Representatives
voted for this bill that would include
even Barbara Lee of Berkeley now if you
remember her name it may be because in
2001 Barbara Lee of Berkeley was the
only member of Congress to oppose the
war against the Taliban
but a war in Ukraine is a war that
Barbara Lee can support why because
there's no
potential chance that war could help the
United States here's her reasoning
this war is not only about Ukraine this
war is about the rest of the world and
Putin trying to establish uh uh
autocratic governments throughout
throughout the world and we know that
this is taking place through this
information campaigns through uh all
kinds of uh misinformation that's taking
place
oh so it's not really about Ukraine it's
about something bigger than Ukraine
thanks Barbara Lee for being dim enough
to tell us that to say it out loud
this is a war on disinformation which at
some point in some way is dead certain
to be a war on you no question about it
because you're a font of disinformation
meaning you disagree
but we know for certain that Wars
against things you can't really identify
against people who don't exist Wars
against Concepts one thing we know about
those Wars like the war on terror is
they last forever
so it was a little weird to see Tim Ryan
of Ohio vote for this Tim Ryan was
supposed to be a working man's Democrat
a guy who cares about bread and butter
issues Tim Ryan represents Youngstown in
Akron
take a look at Akron sometime
it's like a war zone itself
these are the cities that built America
crumbling and desperate now from Total
neglect
but don't you worry Tim Ryan is totally
committed to rebuilding Kiev and so is
Nancy Pelosi for Pelosi funding Ukraine
at any cost is more than a foreign
policy objective it's a kind of
religious observance the brutality of
Putin is not just what he's doing in
Ukraine but the impact that his that it
is having on food for the world so when
you're home thinking what is this all
about just think about when I was hungry
you fed me in the gospel of Matthew
oh so Jesus wants to send more missiles
to Ukraine and the more missiles we send
to Ukraine the less hungry people are
going to be wait a second wouldn't Jesus
want to do everything possible to bring
an end to the war in Ukraine your
religious little twit how dare you quote
that book
by the way there was a time when Nancy
Pelosi didn't want to spend billions of
dollars to secure a country's border she
said it was wasteful and morally wrong
it wasn't that long ago by the way it
was April of 2017. see if you noticed
the difference she's four spending
billions at Borders now she was opposed
to it then what changed watch
the wall is in my view immoral expensive
unwise and when the President says well
I promised a wall during my campaign I I
don't think he said he was going to pass
billions of dollars of cost of the wall
onto the taxpayer oh did you catch that
border secure in the United States is
immoral
but Jesus is strongly for border
security in Ukraine and abortion by the
way it's a sacrament
as usual Democrats as ludicrous as may
sound are united on this point they
stand as one but also as usual a stained
propaganda campaign in the American
Media has managed to divide the
Republican Party
now why does this happen every single
time here's why because Republican
office holders no matter how
conservative they tell you they are
believe the New York Times They care
deeply what Legacy Media say they read
the New York Times every day they don't
want to be criticized by the New York
Times and that's how the left controls
them every single time
if you don't believe it think back the
last two years you saw the same dynamic
in the early days of both the BLM riots
and the covid lockdowns Nancy Pelosi was
out there first taking the most extreme
possible position
and then a lot of Republican leaders
agreed with her
do you remember that two years ago this
month Nikki Haley former governor of
South Carolina running for president
she's conservative she told Americans in
the first days of the riots that they
deserved to suffer after George Floyd
died quote in order to heal it needs to
be personal and painful for everyone she
wrote and in the end it was personal and
painful a lot of people died
and that was good because your racism
killed George Floyd that was Nikki
Haley's first reaction she read it in
the New York Times and she believed that
they all do so it shouldn't shock you
that Nikki Haley's first reaction to the
Russia invasion and Mitch McConnell's
first reaction too and the first
reaction of so many other Republican
leaders was that protecting Ukraine is
way more important than protecting you
than protecting America and Mitch
McConnell hasn't to his credit moved
from that he still thinks it
here he was yesterday
I think we all agree the most important
thing going on in the world right now is
the war in Ukraine
I had a chance to call the president
last week and request that the Ukraine
package moved by itself
and quickly
he said let me think it over he called
back in about 15 minutes and agreed that
we need to do this
Ukraine only
and quickly I think we're on the path to
getting that done
you gotta hope that there's some sincere
billionaire out there who's going to
fund a primary challenge against every
single one of those Republican state
senators standing by Mitch McConnell as
he said and we'll quote again I think we
all agree the most important thing going
on in the world right now is the war in
Ukraine no the most important thing
going on in the world right now is the
state of your country the One You're
supposed to run the people you're
supposed to represent whose lives are
supposed to care about the ones you
can't buy food or gas the people oding
on Fentanyl
107 thousand
in a year dead young people Americans
but that's nothing compared to Ukraine
we all agree Ukraine is the most
important thing really if you agree with
that you should not be sitting in the
United States Senate as a Republican
and yet that's their position of course
it's Lindsey Graham's position just to
give you yet another example
that if Putin's Still Standing after all
this then the world is going to be a
very dark place China's going to get the
wrong signal and we'll have a mess on
our hands in Europe for decades to come
so let's take out Putin by helping
Ukraine all right so you're saying that
that's how this ends that Putin is
removed is there any way there's no
off-ramp there is no off-ramp no
offering let's take out foreign
it's weird to see a guy live out his
strange little fantasy life on TV live
Lindsey Graham won't come on this show
he's afraid we could spend the next hour
playing clips of Lindsey Graham going
back 20 years making predictions that
didn't come true and resulted only in
the death of American servicemen and the
impoverishment of the United States he's
gotten wrong every single time and he's
still out there
let's just take out Putin really what
would happen then the country is 6 000
nuclear weapons
would they be unsecured you thought we
had a mess on our hands with saddam's
arsenals fell into the hands of lunatics
and extremists what would happen to
those 6 000 nuclear weapons if we just
take out Putin
they don't even think about it they
don't care
they're high on their own Supply
Dan Crenshaw of Texas for example not a
stupid guy just announced that we're
quote investing in the destruction of
our adversary's military when we spend
40 billion on Ukraine investing in the
destruction of our adversaries and
Military since when did we declare war
on Russia
did anybody vote for that are
adversaries military that's what you do
in war
since when are we fighting Russia well
since Putin stole the election from
Hillary Clinton glad to see that Dan
Crenshaw has signed up for this new
campaign
but you got to wonder at what cost not
just the Peril the real Peril that this
could escalate into something
crushing for the West
but what immediate cost to the United
States and our own ability to defend
ourselves all these people who love the
military do they ever ask that question
right now Joe Biden in the U.S Congress
have sent so much military aid to
Ukraine that our country the United
States is running out of weapons
according to Bloomberg quote Pentagon
officials say that Kiev is blowing
through a week's worth of deliveries of
anti-tank Munitions every day it's also
running short of usable aircraft as
Russian airstrikes and combat losses
take their toll ammunition has become
scarce in marapola and other areas in
Ukraine this is presenting Western
countries with a stark choice between
pouring more supplies into Ukraine or
husbanding finite capabilities they may
need for their own defense
that's the line they may need for their
own defense it's a scary world and if
you blow it all on Ukraine with finite
resources which we have sorry
where does that leave you undefended
now this is happening because senior
leaders of the Republican Party
instantly bought the New York Times
position on Ukraine as they instantly
bought the New York Times position
on the BLM riots as they instantly
bought the position of the New York
Times on the coveted lockdowns they
didn't question what they read
and the consequences now we are short on
weapons to defend our own country
now no Democrat ever goes against his
own herd ever the first reaction of
every Democrat is always to read
whatever talking points Nancy Pelosi
provides they never listen to the other
side
they always go farther in One Direction
and the Republican party is always led
by people who join them
here for example is how Congressman
Jamie Raskin of Maryland responded when
Marjorie Taylor green of Georgia raised
an objection with well wait what about
our country she said here's what he said
back
40 billion dollars
but there's no baby formula for American
mothers and babies
an unknown amount of money to the CIA in
the Ukraine supplemental bill but
there's no formula for American babies
and mothers we should be paying
attention to our country right now I
yield back thank you June lady yields
back the gentleman gentlewoman from
Minnesota Reserve gentleman from
Maryland is recognized thank you madam
speaker here's a formula for the
destruction of democracy repeating
Putin's propaganda and disinformation
and appeasing imperialist assaults on
Sovereign Nations
so you can't buy baby formula in the
United States and maybe you think you
can do both at once you can fund Ukraine
and
get baby formula for American babies
maybe you can fix inflation and also
fund Ukraine speak slowly and tell us
how that works maybe there's an answer
to the question but notice they don't
answer
they just accuse the person asking the
question of working for Putin you're
looking for Putin you're against
democracy they don't tell us how Ukraine
is a democracy they banned the
opposition party that's a democracy
but maybe there's an answer what is it
stop name calling and answer the
question but Jamie Raskin won't do that
none of them will he screams about Putin
now 57 Republicans did vote against last
night's Bill and God blessed them for
doing it but many more voted for it of
course there was Liz Cheney and Adam
kinzinger their friend Elise stefanik
but there was also Republican leadership
top leadership McCarthy and scalise
shameful
and the worst part is this bill will
almost certainly pass in the Senate
which is way more left-wing even than
the house on the Republican side Chuck
Schumer is promising a swift vote on it
that means as soon as tomorrow so we
reached out to every Republican in the
Senate to find out what they planned to
do most of them didn't bother to reply
none of them will come on the show that
would include Mitch McConnell the
minority leader Ted Cruz Mike Lee Chuck
Grassley Mitt Romney also did not
respond we're hoping they'll vote the
right way but a handful of senators did
respond and we want to let you know
where they stand voting no will be Mike
Braun Roger Marshall Marcia Blackburn
Bill Hagerty and Josh Hawley Rand Paul
is also indicated he's opposed the bill
he wouldn't say so but of course he's
against it Lindsey Graham needless to
say is a yes he is thrilled as his
office put it Senator Graham has made it
clear he supports additional military
aid to Ukraine because it makes him feel
so good inside he didn't say that but
that's the truth
Rob Portman of Ohio is leaving thank
heaven he's also a yes so is Steve Danes
in Montana quote the center is leading
yes his office said they also told us
that Danes thinks Russian oligarchs
somehow will pay the 40 billion quote he
wants to make Russia cover the cost he
wants to use the seized assets of
oligarchs to cover the costs
right okay
a few Senators Dodge Pat Toomey Tim
Scott Cindy Hyde Smith all refused to
give us a direct answer we want to
invite any Republican senator who plans
on voting for this to come on the show
and explain why please tell us we'll let
you talk as much as you want we're not
going to sandbag you we want to know why
this isn't America's interest why this
is more important than the pressing
crises all around us that the rest of us
notice and apparently you don't so tell
us you're always welcome
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight